Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambhodasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambhodasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambhodasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
So, this evening, I just want to cover a sort of basic ground.
For some of you, it's hopefully a timely reminder, and for others, maybe some new information.
Donc ce soir je voudrais poser des bases, et pour certains d'entre vous ce sera un rappel, et pour d'autres ce sera une découverte.
Donc il y a trois choses qui doivent être claires pour nous, en nous pratiquant vipassana.
ou même dans la vie courante ?
D'abord, comprendre ce que veut dire le Bouddha quand il parle de l'attention juste.
Et comment les utiliser ?
Et comment gérons-nous les états mentaux qui nous détournent de l'attention juste ?
Et comment est-ce que nous les utilisons ?
Et finalement, qu'est-ce qu'on est vraiment en train d'investiguer, d'explorer ?
Et donc la première question, qu'est-ce que c'est l'attention juste, est exemplifiée par l'histoire du bouquin lui-même.
Rappelez-vous, il a laissé sa famille avec ce que nous reconnaissons comme une crise existentielle.
Et donc, il a quitté sa famille à la suite de ce que nous appellerons une crise existentielle.
Donc, d'une façon ou d'une autre, quand il était jeune, à l'âge de 20 ans, il est devenu conscient
des quatre messagers divins.
Il a vu une personne très âgée, une personne morte, donc un corps, une personne très malade,
et aussi un moine assis sous un arbre.
Cette histoire sert à illustrer le fait que
À un moment dans notre vie, comme nous avons plus de moins 20 ans, nous commençons à nous rendre compte que la vie n'est pas toute rose, qu'elle n'est pas toujours facile.
Il y en a aussi qui ne s'en rendent pas compte avant d'être plus âgés, à la quarantaine, à la cinquantaine.
Et certaines pauvres personnes n'y arrivent pas jusqu'à leur âge.
Le fait que nous soyons tous ici signifie qu'à un moment donné dans nos vies, nous avons réalisé qu'il y a une maladie, qu'il y aura de l'âge et qu'il y aura la mort qui nous attend, et qu'il y a peut-être une évasion de la souffrance que cela nous cause.
Le fait que nous sommes tous là veut dire qu'à un certain moment, nous avons sans doute réalisé qu'il y a la vieillesse, il y a la maladie et que nous allons mourir et qu'il y a peut-être une façon d'échapper à la souffrance que cette réalisation nous cause.
Évidemment, ces choses sont tout à fait naturelles.
Elles font partie de la vie.
Nous vieillissons, nous devenons malades et puis nous mourons.
Comme le comédien a dit, la vie est difficile et puis vous mourrez.
Comme a dit le comédien, la vie est dure et puis on meurt.
Il essaye d'abord de faire des méditations de différents types pour établir de très beaux états mentaux.
Le Bouddha a commencé par explorer différentes formes de méditation qui ont résulté dans des états d'esprit très merveilleux.
Dans toutes ces pratiques particulières que nous appelons méditation d'absorption ou méditation de concentration, ils n'ont pas répondu à ce problème existentiel profond.
Et toutes ces pratiques qu'il a explorées, qui étaient surtout des pratiques que nous appelons les pratiques de concentration, d'absorption, il s'est rendu compte qu'elle ne répondait pas à cette question existentielle qu'il avait.
Vous savez, pourquoi sommes-nous nés ?
Pourquoi devons-nous mourir ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est tout ?
Ce genre de questions.
Ils n'ont pas répondu à ça.
Une des questions, c'est pourquoi sommes-nous nés ?
Pourquoi devons-nous mourir ?
Qu'est-ce que cela veut dire ?
C'est une grande question.
Alors cette pratique ne fournissait pas la réponse.
Je pense que j'ai raison en disant qu'il n'y a qu'une seule occasion, excusez-moi, qu'il n'y a qu'une seule occasion dans les scriptures comme tel
où le Bouddha parle d'une expérience qui lui est arrivée quand il était enfant.
C'était une occasion où il regardait son père
C'était une occasion où, quand il était jeune, il était en train de regarder son père participer à une cérémonie qui ouvrait la saison des labours.
Et on doit s'imaginer quand il a eu ce premier, après avoir essayé toutes sortes de différentes pratiques et surtout des mortifications,
Il était dans un état de commandement.
C'était pour elle.
Il semblerait qu'il était à côté de la rue, probablement en train de se demander ce qu'il devait faire maintenant, quand une femme est venue offrir de la viande à un château, et en voyant ce pauvre pauvre, il l'a offert à lui.
Et donc, selon l'histoire, le Bouddha était assis, népité, au bord de la route, et une jeune femme est passée avec du riz sucré qu'il allait offrir à un hôtel.
Et le voyant dans cet état, elle a offert cette nourriture
au Bouddha à la place.
Et donc, cela semblait qu'à ce moment-là, le Bouddha eût ce souvenir de quand il était enfant.
Et ce qu'il dit dans l'histoire, dans les écrits, c'est que quand il était enfant, le Bouddha était dans le même état de concentration qu'il avait pratiqué plus tard avec ses enseignants.
Mais il y avait clairement quelque chose qui était différent.
Et c'était, bien sûr, cette question qui se marquait dans son esprit, ce qu'il se demandait de faire avec son père.
Nous l'appelons les vipassanas.
Nous appelons cela les vipassana-jhāna, ou les états d'absorption vipassana.
En d'autres mots, dans notre pratique, nous pouvons nous concentrer autant que quelqu'un qui pratique le jhāna, mais il y a cette qualité d'investigation.
Donc, dans notre façon de pratiquer, on peut atteindre des niveaux de concentration qui sont aussi élevés que ceux qui pratiquent les jhanas, donc la concentration.
Mais la différence est que notre approche a cette qualité d'investigation.
C'est la différence cruciale.
Il y a vraiment la différence absolument cruciale.
Si vous imaginez un enfant de peut-être 7 ans, bien qu'on voit aussi ce genre d'émerveillement chez l'enfant jusqu'à l'âge de 10 ans,
mais qui ont cette espèce d'émerveillement sur leur visage.
Ça peut aussi nous arriver en tant qu'adultes.
Alors quand un enfant, et quelquefois nous, quand un enfant voit quelque chose qu'il ne connaît pas, il s'arrête net et le regarde intensément.
Et ils ont la bouche ouverte, ce qui les rend un peu idiots.
Donc, le bon parent leur dit immédiatement, arrête ça, réveille-toi, et ils empêchent de venir réveiller à ce moment-là.
Une méditante m'a dit que son père lui disait de garder la bouche fermée, sinon une mouche pourrait y entrer.
Et quand nous voyons quelqu'un qui a cette air que nous faisons nous-mêmes, avec la bouche ouverte, vraiment regarder, ce qui est en train de se passer, c'est en fait que nous avons arrêté de penser.
Et que la mâchoire se soit détendue, que la bouche soit ouverte, tout ça c'est vraiment lié de façon très intime à la pensée.
Quand la bouche est ouverte, cela nous dit qu'il n'y a aucune pensée.
Et donc, c'est vide de penser, mais ça veut dire qu'il n'y a pas de pensée conceptuelle.
On est en contact direct avec l'information qui est en train de...
d'entrer en train de processer, de traiter directement cette information.
Donc, quand un enfant fait ça, bien sûr, il va garder son regard pendant un moment, et puis, bien sûr, il va se tourner et se demander, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Et quand un enfant fait ça, ils vont regarder ce qu'ils ne reconnaissent pas pendant un moment, et puis ils vont se retourner vers quelqu'un et demander « mais qu'est-ce que c'est ?
».
Et une fois que le parent a dit « une araignée », par exemple,
Alors ça, c'est la note, le petit mot.
Et c'est le début d'avoir un concept des araignées.
Et donc, la prochaine fois qu'un enfant voit...
Ils voient une araignée, ils crient « Ah voilà, une araignée, une araignée !
» Ah, et maman et papa disent « Oh, très bien, très bien !
» Mais le enfant n'a jamais regardé correctement cette espèce, pas de la manière dont ils ont vu la première espèce.
Ils l'ont simplement intégrée dans leur perception.
Mais l'enfant n'a plus regardé l'araignée de la même façon.
En fait, il n'a pas regardé du tout.
Pas comme la première fois.
Tout ce qu'il a fait, c'est, disons, la mettre dans une boîte, donner l'araignée.
Et c'est ce que nous faisons tout le temps.
Donc, c'est ce que nous faisons, et à chaque fois que nous voyons quelque chose, que nous en soyons conscients ou pas, nous avons un libellé pour cette chose, et que nous lui donnons.
Et comme on disait ce matin,
C'est la raison d'utiliser cette notation, ce nom, parce que ça devient très clair pour nous ce qui est en train de se passer.
Et il y a une autre raison pour noter, c'est que ça nous donne une certaine distance de l'objet.
Et nous reviendrons là-dessus à la fin de l'enseignement.
Donc, cette façon de regarder les choses a deux qualités.
la conscience intuitive qui vraiment s'accroche à l'objet, et aussi l'intelligence... Non, arrête, arrête.
Non ?
C'est l'awareness qui reçoit l'information.
Ah, donc la conscience intuitive qui reçoit
l'attention qui reçoit l'information et puis la conscience intuitive qui...
L'intelligence.
L'intelligence intuitive qui vraiment... Did you say grasps it?
Yes, so understands, that grasps and understands what's going on.
D'accord, donc l'intelligence intuitive qui voit ce qui se passe et qui
Et donc quand le Bouddha parle d'établir ce genre de conscience,
Il parle toujours de sati sampajana, c'est-à-dire l'attention avec l'intelligence intuitive.
Il y a un très bon enseignant en Thaïlande, Buddha Dasa, qui a utilisé le mot satipanya pour référer au Bouddha à l'intérieur.
C'est un enseignant thaï, Ajahn Buddhadas, qui a utilisé le terme Satipanya pour nommer le Bouddha intérieur.
Cela nous donne une idée de ce que c'est et notre travail c'est de constamment
revenir à cette conscience intuitive pure.
Et ce qui nous empêche d'y arriver, c'est ce que le Bouddha appelle les obstacles, les empêchements.
Il y en a cinq, et chacun d'entre eux nous dit quel est le problème et comment nous devons nous y attaquer.
Le premier, bien sûr, concerne le désir, ce que nous voulons.
Et donc le premier empêchement concerne le désir, ce que l'on veut.
Donc par exemple, si dans notre méditation nous sommes entourés de cette fantaisie, de ce rêve de voyager à Machu Picchu ou d'un pays étranger,
Donc si dans notre méditation on se retrouve complètement pris par un désir d'aller voyager à Machu Picchu, quelque part d'exotique, si on ne fait pas attention, alors ça va vraiment submerger notre méditation.
J'ai un ami qui a pratiqué pendant trois mois l'IMS, le centre aux États-Unis, commencé par Joseph Goldstein et Sharon Salzberg.
Et il m'a dit qu'il avait passé presque tous les trois mois à planifier un voyage en Amérique du Sud.
Bien sûr, l'ironie, c'est qu'il n'y a jamais été.
Ces fantasies peuvent avoir une grande prise sur nous.
La raison pour laquelle, et c'est vrai pour toutes les hindrances, c'est que ces états mentaux sont comme des attitudes, ils sont comme des ballons.
Et donc, la raison pour laquelle les empêchements ont une telle emprise, c'est qu'elles sont comme des attitudes, elles sont comme des ballons.
Donc, nous avons une attitude de...
de nous accrocher à ce que nous voulons.
C'est une attitude interne envers quelque chose qui est désirable.
Ce n'est pas ce que nous désirons qui cause cette attitude, c'est l'attitude qui crée cette mauvaise relation avec ce que nous voulons.
Ce n'est pas ce que nous désirons qui crée cette attitude, c'est notre relation qui n'est pas juste avec le désir qui crée...
C'est impossible de se souvenir de ce que j'ai dit.
C'est quelque chose de...
Ce n'est pas l'objet qui crée l'attitude, c'est l'attitude qui se crée autour d'un objet.
Quand je fais ça, par exemple, c'est pour éliminer le flic.
Donc, quand quelque chose se manifeste qui nous attire, c'est comme
Et tout ce qui est dans le ballon veut s'échapper par ce petit trou.
Et si votre concentration est bonne, c'est comme si vous étiez en train de comprimer le ballon.
Donc, tout sort encore plus vite avec beaucoup de force.
Alors, dès que l'on voit l'esprit qui est distrait par une fantaisie, il faut vraiment être là avec.
Donc, on utilise ce mot « planifier, planifier » et ça nous permet de voir ce que l'esprit est en train de faire et d'avoir une réflexion.
sur ce que l'esprit est en train de faire.
Et dès qu'on le reconnaît, on sait ce qu'on doit faire pour l'empêcher d'aller plus loin.
Et c'est bien possible que le désir soit si fort que l'on puisse le ressentir dans le corps comme une énergie, une excitation.
Et donc, à ce moment-là, le mot utilisé pourrait changer pour devenir « excitation, excitation ».
Et on est en train d'utiliser le mot pour que vraiment l'attention soit fermement plantée, ancrée dans le ressenti qui est manifesté.
Dans le discours sur l'établissement de l'attention, le Bouddha utilise cette phrase de sentir les ressentis dans les ressentis.
De ressentir des ressentis physiques dans les ressentis physiques.
De ressentir des états mentaux dans les états mentaux.
Et donc, il me semble qu'il avait aussi ce problème de faire en sorte que les gens vraiment ressentent les sensations, les ressentis.
Donc, quand vous avez noté « planning, planning » et que vous revenez et que vous pouvez ressentir cela, si ce n'est pas le cas, vous retournez à l'esprit, vous continuez à utiliser ces mots de note pour rester avec ce que vous expérimentez.
Et donc, après avoir utilisé ces mots planifié, planifié, peut-être vous ne le sentez pas, alors vous retournez, vous ne ressentez rien, donc vous retournez vers la respiration et vous continuez à utiliser ces notes pour vraiment être avec ce que vous êtes en train de, avec l'expérience elle-même.
Et...
Et quand vous le faites, quand vous êtes vraiment là, vous allez peut-être remarquer qu'il y a une petite tendance, une petite énergie à vouloir s'échapper.
à vouloir retourner au rêve.
Et donc on doit être très conscient de cela, parce que juste une nanoseconde d'inattention et on est parti d'autre part.
Il faut se rappeler que l'esprit est vraiment vif et s'il est inattentif pour une seconde, il est juste parti.
Notre travail, c'est vraiment de rester planté avec l'expérience, comme elle se déroule.
Tout cela est aussi vrai pour les autres empêchements.
et quand il s'agit de choses que nous n'aimons pas, il y en a plus ou moins deux catégories.
La première catégorie consiste dans les états mentaux que nous aimons,
dans lesquels nous aimons nous complaire, comme peut-être la colère.
Et il y en a d'autres, comme peut-être une peine très profonde, que nous n'aimons pas ressentir.
Et aussi dans cette deuxième catégorie, il y aurait des choses comme la jalousie, que nous trouvons très très difficile à vraiment laisser...
Et donc, avec la colère, par exemple, souvent on la traite beaucoup de la même manière que les choses que nous désirons.
Et quand il s'agit de choses qui sont difficiles pour nous de ressentir, la dépression, une tristesse profonde,
alors nous devons être conscients de notre tendance à les refiler, à les rejeter.
Et donc, nous devons être conscients de notre envie de ne pas les...
ne pas les expérimenter, et puis développer une attitude de bienveillance.
Alors, par exemple, prenons la solitude.
Personne n'aime se sentir seul.
On préfère regarder la télévision, cuisiner, appeler un ami.
Tout s'offre comment se sentir seul et isolé.
En fait, nous devons nous ouvrir à ce sentiment et vraiment écouter ce qu'il est en train de nous dire.
Donc, tu...
Personne ne t'aime, personne ne pourrait t'aimer, tu vas toujours être seul et c'est bien comme ça.
Tout fait l'ordre de choses.
Et donc, plutôt, nous nous ouvrons à ce genre d'expérience
Nous avons une attitude d'inveillance envers cette urgence.
Maintenant, si nous pouvons rester jusqu'à la fin de cette énergie émotionnelle, pour rester jusqu'à la fin, nous pouvons réellement expérimenter la transformation.
Et donc si nous arrivons à vraiment être présents avec ce sentiment jusqu'à sa fin, alors nous pouvons peut-être avoir l'expérience de sa transformation.
Rien n'est perdu dans ce processus.
Tout est transformé.
Rien n'est perdu dans tous ces processus, tout se transforme.
On était égoïste, on se trouve devenir être généreux.
On était plein de haine et en colère, on se trouve en train d'être...
tolérant, aimant.
Là, on était cruel et malveillant, on se retrouve en train d'être plus compassionné, plus bienveillant.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose que nous devons faire, c'est quelque chose qui se passe tout à fait naturellement.
Le corps se guérit dans la conscience.
Et c'est comparable à une blessure qui se guérit.
Donc, quand on se coupe avec un couteau, le corps se guérit lui-même.
Notre rôle, c'est de garder la blessure propre.
Oui, antiseptique.
Donc, antiseptique.
Désinfectique.
Nous gardons le cœur de partir dans une sepsis, dans une inflammation, en étant conscients.
Donc nous empêchons le corps de devenir infecté, inflammé, en étant conscient.
Donc maintenant, la troisième chose est la douleur et la lethargie, mais on y reviendra.
La quatrième chose est cette restreinte et toutes ces émotions que nous avons quand nous faisons quelque chose de dangereux.
Donc, le troisième empêchement, c'est la torpeur et la somnolence, mais nous allons y revenir.
Et puis, le quatrième, c'est l'agitation et toutes les choses qui font que nous faisons des choses qui sont malsaines.
Donc, c'est un peu une catégorie pour qui on peut fourrer tout, donc si votre état ne correspond pas aux trois autres
aux quatre autres empêchements, alors l'agitation couvre un peu tous ces états.
Quand on est agité de cette façon, c'est très difficile de rester
Donc, on est tranquille avec le corps agité et l'esprit qui veut aller dans tous les sens.
Donc, quand on a vraiment cette agitation du corps, essayez de vous détendre autour du corps.
Quand vous ressentez cette agitation, cette tension, quoi que vous puissiez relâcher, détendre, faites-le.
Et c'est quelquefois utile de simplement faire un balayage de la tête jusqu'aux pieds, en vraiment explorant les endroits où vous ressentez vraiment cette agitation.
Mais si vous pouvez, comme toutes ces choses, si vous pouvez mettre votre attention dans cette restreinte, vous donnez au cœur une chance de relancer cette énergie.
Mais si vous y arrivez, vous restez vraiment planté, présent avec cette agitation là où elle se manifeste, vous êtes en train de donner au cœur la possibilité de se guérir de cette agitation.
When it comes to the other part of that particular hindrance, it's to do with guilt and shame.
Et puis, il y a un autre aspect de cet empêchement qui a à voir avec l'inculpabilité et...
Merci.
Yeah, aunt, isn't it?
Donc nous les traitons comme les autres que nous trouvons très difficiles à assumer.
Arise parce que nous avons fait quelque chose de mal, alors nous devons essayer de faire ce que nous pouvons pour mettre ça en place.
C'est simple.
Évidemment, si nous nous sentons coupables parce que nous avons fait quelque chose qui a fait du mal, alors évidemment, il faut essayer de réparer si possible.
Oui.
Et la honte, c'est le sentiment de perdre l'estime de soi.
Si vous pouvez faire quelque chose qui vous aide à rééquilibrer, qui vous fait reprendre un peu de votre estime de soi, c'est aussi très utile.
Il faut aussi se rappeler que pour la plupart, nos sentiments de culpabilité et de honte sont exagérés.
C'est un peu comme avec le désir.
Les sentiments de honte sont comme des ballons pour toutes les choses terribles que nous avons faites dans notre vie et nous nous sentons coupables.
chose énorme pour toutes les choses honteuses que nous avons fait dans notre vie.
Donc, parfois, la culpabilité et la honte que nous ressentons par rapport à quelque chose n'est vraiment pas proportionnelle.
Et donc c'est la même chose, il faut laisser ces choses se manifester et vous êtes en train de vider le cœur de ces états mentaux malsains.
Et de même avec le doute.
Et ici, on parle du doute sceptique.
Donc, c'est le doute qui nous empêche d'agir.
C'est une force qui peut être assez destructrice dans nos vies.
Et ça provient d'un peur de faillite, d'une faillite de confiance.
Tu appliques pour un travail, et tout ce doute s'éloigne, « peux-je le faire, suis-je assez bon ?
» Et pendant que tu es perdue dans ton doute, le travail va à quelqu'un d'autre.
Donc, c'est cette peur de l'échec et par exemple, on veut un travail et puis quand on se dit qu'on n'est pas assez bon et puis on n'agit pas et puis le travail est donné à quelqu'un d'autre.
C'est la même chose avec la relation.
Je ne suis pas assez bon, peut-être qu'ils ne m'aiment pas.
Et avant que tu te rendes compte, ils sont allés et ont trouvé quelqu'un d'autre.
C'est la même chose avec des gens, peut-être quelqu'un qu'on aime bien, on se dit je ne suis pas assez bien, il ne m'aime pas et puis on n'agit pas et il repart avec quelqu'un d'autre.
Voilà.
Dans notre méditation, normalement, maintenant qu'on se situe et qu'on pratique, nos doutes ne sont pas tant dans le Bouddha, ou dans le enseignement, ou dans la pratique.
C'est généralement dans nous-mêmes.
Je ne suis pas assez bon, je n'arrive pas à quelque chose.
Je ne vois pas de progrès.
Et donc, comme nous sommes en train de pratiquer, notre doute n'est pas tellement dirigé vers le Bouddha et les enseignements, mais plutôt vers nous-mêmes.
Disons, je ne me fais pas assez bien, je ne suis pas assez douée, assez habile, et nous dirigeons ces choses vers nous-mêmes.
C'est la même chose, donc il faut vraiment rester avec ce sentiment de
d'échec, des sentiments de doute, ces sentiments de ne pas être à la hauteur, et puis de voir le changement.
Pour retourner à la torpeur et la somnolence, ce sont des énergies très lourdes.
qui nous terrassent et qui nous font descendre dans le corps.
Vers le néant.
Et bien sûr, il n'y a pas de souffrance dans le néant, mais il n'y a pas d'éveil non plus.
Donc, on fait le son mieux pour rester réveillé.
Et de nouveau, tout ce que l'on fait, c'est qu'on permet au cœur de relâcher cette énergie malsaine.
Il faut vraiment le sentir.
Vous pouvez regarder les différents endroits dans le corps où vous ressentez cette fatigue, cette somnolence.
Cela vous permet de rester réveillé.
Chaque fois qu'il y a cette attention, il y a aussi une intention, et cette intention donne un peu de pouvoir.
Et même si c'est une torpeur dans la tête, alors simplement, bougez votre attention dans la tête.
Regardez différentes choses.
Et donc, ce qui se passe, c'est que non seulement cette énergie malsaine, en l'observant, lui permettait de se relâcher,
mais aussi ça nous permet de se transformer en énergie pure.
Et donc, comme nous avons expliqué les cinq empêchements,
Nous pouvons voir que c'est notre relation avec ces états qui est le problème.
J'ai oublié la dernière partie de la sentence.
Désolée.
Donc, ce que nous sommes en train de regarder, de contempler, c'est le désir
le vouloir, le ne pas vouloir, le désir et l'aversion.
Voilà.
Et ça, c'est un niveau de la libération.
Et donc, une des voies vers la libération est de comprendre le processus du mauvais désir.
Le deuxième est de voir l'impermanence.
Et dans notre pratique, c'est assez facile à voir.
Il n'y a aucune respiration qui se répète, aucune pensée.
Rien ne se répète.
Nous sommes très rapides à voir quelque chose de nouveau.
Mais nous n'aimons pas voir le fin des choses.
Mais on n'aime pas voir la fin des choses.
Avant la fin de quelque chose, nous sommes déjà en train de penser à la prochaine chose, la prochaine chose, le prochain film à regarder, la prochaine personne à qui parler.
La prochaine chose à voir.
Nous sommes toujours un peu au-devant de nous-mêmes.
La raison pour laquelle nous faisons ça, c'est que toutes les fins sont une mort.
Une petite mort, mais une mort.
sur la fin des choses, la fin d'un pas, la fin d'une respiration.
Toujours la fin.
Et c'est ainsi que nous subissons ce sens de soi, parce que le soi veut toujours savoir ce qui viendra.
Il n'aime pas ne pas savoir ce qui viendra.
Et c'est une façon aussi d'aller contre le sens du soi, parce que le sens du soi veut toujours savoir ce qui vient, ce qui va venir, ce qui va se passer.
Et pour comprendre le non-soi, la façon la plus facile, c'est de regarder ce que l'on peut contrôler et ce qu'on ne peut pas contrôler.
D'une façon très simple, quand nous parlons du corps, nous disons j'ai un mal de tête, mais je suis malade.
Et ça, c'est une possession et une identification avec cet organisme.
Et c'est alors qu'on peut commencer à reconnaître
Nous n'avons qu'un contrôle minimal.
Périphéral, non.
Ça veut dire que, par exemple, nous ne savons pas ce que notre foi est en train de faire juste maintenant.
Donc, très rapidement, ce sont les trois avenues d'investigation qui conduisent à la libération.
Donc, le premier, rappelez-vous, c'est ce désir faux.
La deuxième, l'impermanence.
Et la troisième, le non-soi.
Donc le premier, c'est le désir faux.
Le deuxième, c'est l'impermanence.
Et le troisième, c'est le non-soi.
Et le noter, vous voyez, nous aide à distancer de ce que nous expérimentons.
Donc, par exemple, si vous avez une douleur dans le dos, vous pouvez dire « Il y a une douleur.
»
C'est autre, c'est quelque chose que vous expérimentez, qui n'est pas la même chose que ce que vous expérimentez.
Noter nous permet de nous distancer de notre expérience.
Par exemple, si nous avons mal au genou,
alors la douleur, elle est là, elle est là-bas, dans là-bas.
Et donc on dit « teindre » entre ce qui est expérimenté et ce qui est en train d'expérimenter.
Donc ce soir, nous avons parlé de l'attention juste, le visage de l'enfant.
Comment gérer ces hindrances un peu ?
Comment s'approcher, comment gérer les empêchements ?
Pour faire en sorte que les empêchements eux-mêmes deviennent un chemin vers la libération.
Et de voir que tout ce dont nous avons l'expérience est un objet que nous ne contrôlons pas directement.
Que je ne souhaitais que ce que j'ai dit vous ait aidé.
que je ne vous ai pas causé de la confusion et que vous serez libérés de toute votre souffrance, tôt plutôt que tard.